[Música]
el departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos reveló un informe que detalla que
el cuerpo policial de Mineápolis estuvo
dominado durante años por un racismo
sistemático y discriminación de minorías
es el resultado de la investigación
abierta tras el asesinato del joven afro
estadounidense George Floyd
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken partió hacia
china previo a su despegue aseguró que
su misión será mantener abiertas las
relaciones entre Washington y Beijing el
funcionario llegará a China el domingo y
estará en esta nación hasta el lunes
en Brasil la Corte Suprema autorizó que
la policía federal le tome una nueva
declaración al expresidente Jair
bolsonaro en medio de la investigación
por una presunta trama golpista esto
luego de que se conocieran mensajes del
teléfono de un militar ha llegado
bolsonaro que confirman que el círculo
cercano del exmandatario quería bloquear
la victoria de Lula
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos el departamento de
Justicia presentó una investigación que
confirma la existencia de abusos
sistemáticos por parte del departamento
de policía de Minneapolis hacia la
comunidad afrodescendiente una de las
víctimas de este patrón de brutalidad
policial fue George Floyd ya que el
informe descubrió que la gente
responsable de su muerte dereckving
tenía un historial de abusos raciales
mientras portaba el uniforme Max Pérez
Gallardo nos trae la historia
la muerte de George Floyd fue producto
del racismo sistemático un informe
presentado por el fiscal general de
Estados Unidos Maryland concluyó que
dentro del departamento de policía de la
ciudad de Minneapolis existe un patrón
sobre el uso excesivo de la fuerza
contra la población afrodescendiente y
de comunidades indígenas
descubrimos que el departamento de
policía de Minneapolis utiliza
habitualmente fuerza excesiva a menudo
cuando no es necesaria incluida la
fuerza letal injusta y el uso
irrazonable de armas teiser los agentes
del departamento disparaban armas de
fuego a las personas sin evaluar si
representaba alguna amenaza y mucho
menos una amenaza que justificaría la
fuerza letal
la investigación inició en 2021 y fue
encabezada por el Departamento de
Justicia estadounidense en ella se
revela que dereckhaobin oficial que
asesinó a George Floyd después de
arrodillarse en su cuello por más de 9
minutos ya había presentado un
comportamiento abusivo en el pasado Pero
el departamento policial no hizo nada el
jefe de la policía de la ciudad afirma
que reconocen sus errores y que están
trabajando para enmendarlos
estoy aquí hoy en nombre de la policía
de Minneapolis para firmar nuestro
compromiso de avanzar juntos es nuestro
momento de liderar sanar reconstruir y
crear el tipo de departamento de policía
que todos los residentes de Minneapolis
Pérez
el asesinato de George Floyd en mayo de
2020 detonó una serie de protestas de la
comunidad afroamericana en Minneapolis
denunciando la brutalidad policial de la
que han sido objeto históricamente y que
hoy fue confirmada en el informe el 27
de octubre de 2018 se registró uno de
los ataques más mortíferos contra la
comunidad judía en la historia de
Estados Unidos un hombre armado entró a
una sinagoga en Pittsburgh en
Pensilvania y disparó contra los
asistentes matando a 11 personas el
atacante fue declarado culpable por un
Jurado Federal que ahora tendrá que
decidir si enfrenta la cadena perpetua o
la pena de muerte un equipo en terreno
nos trae la historia de dos periodistas
que fueron clave para investigar los
hechos
son reactores en dos medios de
Pittsburgh el Pittsburgh Just chronicle
y el Pittsburg Union progress pero
decidieron unir fuerzas para cubrir el
juicio del hombre que mató a 11 personas
en una sinagoga local en 2018
estábamos hechos para cubrir esta
historia juntos porque residíamos allí
mismo literalmente en la comunidad que
ha estado cubriéndolo durante todo este
tiempo además nuestra gente en terreno
cubrió incluso antes de que se
identificara el tirador
es un servicio público cubrir esta
historia no es como el caso scoopy donde
alguien va a obtener una mejor historia
de todos modos
trabajar juntos requirió algunos ajustes
como decidir si usar o no el nombre del
tirador
Cuanto más se difunde su nombre más se
le da fama Y glorificación eso es
definitivamente Algo que queremos evitar
siempre utilizaríamos el nombre porque
eso también es Pero somos conscientes de
que no es necesario utilizarlo 30 veces
en un mismo reportaje
cada día un reportero de una u otra
redacción acudía al tribunal para
informar sobre los procedimientos y sus
artículos eran publicados por ambos
medios Adam rainers formó parte del
equipo que cubrió el juicio
personalmente ha sido extremadamente
beneficioso trabajar juntos y contar con
otro grupo de periodistas talentosos que
se preocupan por la historia que se
preocupan Por hacerlo bien que tienen
ideas similares en cuanto a lo que
significa hacerlo bien lo que significa
hacer lo correcto por la gente
el juicio entrará ahora en una nueva
fase en la que los mismos miembros del
Jurado decidirán la condena del
Pistolero cadena perpetua o pena de
muerte el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken partió
hacia china previamente en un
pronunciamiento aseguró que su misión es
mantener abierta la comunicación entre
ambas naciones y Buscar que la
competencia comercial con china no
escale hasta convertirse en un conflicto
el viaje a China tiene como primer
objetivo establecer comunicaciones
abiertas y empoderadas para que nuestros
dos países manejen responsablemente la
relación incluso discutiendo desafíos al
abordar a las percepciones erróneas y
evitar errores de cálculo
vamos a Perú este viernes el ex asesor
del entonces presidente Alberto fujimori
vladimiro Montesinos fue condenado a 23
años de prisión por el asesinato y
descuartizamiento de la gente de
inteligencia Mariela barreto en 1997 los
detalles los tiene desde Lima nuestro
corresponsal Francisco Zacarías luego de
26 años de la muerte de la gente de
inteligencia Mariela barreto la justicia
peruana condenó a 23 años de cárcel a
vladimiro Montesinos ex asesor el
expresidente Alberto fujimori por ser el
autor mediato del secuestro y asesinato
de barreto en 1997 la gente barreto
reveló los crímenes del grupo colina un
escuadrón paramilitar que ejecutó las
matanzas de la cantuta y barrios altos
Así mismo denunció planes que tenía el
comando para atentar contra periodistas
que criticaban al entonces gobierno de
Alberto fujimori según la cuarta sala
penal liquidadora transitoria de la
corte superior nacional vladimiro
Montesinos quien era jefe en las sombras
el servicio de inteligencia ordenó
asesinar a Mariela barreto A mediados de
marzo de 1997 su cuerpo descuartizado
fue hallado en dos bolsas en una
carretera al norte de Lima junto con
Montesinos también fueron condenados el
ex mayor del ejército Santiago Martín
Rivas y los oficiales Carlos Sánchez y
José Salinas al finalizar la audiencia
vladimiro Montesinos Quien cumple una
condena de 25 años por violación a los
derechos humanos y corrupción se reservó
el derecho de apelar la sentencia las
autoridades calculan que al grupo colina
asesinó en Perú a 25 personas entre los
años 1991 y 1992 al ejecutar operativos
clandestinos para desactivar a los
grupos alzados en armas de sendero
luminoso y el movimiento revolucionario
túpac Amaru vamos a Brasil porque la
Corte Suprema de ese país autorizó que
la policía federal tome una nueva
declaración al expresidente Jair
bolsonaro en medio de la investigación
sobre una presunta trama golpista que
intentaban partidarios y militares para
mantener al ultraderechista en el poder
previamente nuestra corresponsal en
Brasil Valeria sacone nos contó detalles
de la investigación que envuelve a
bolsonar
cada vez aparecen más evidencias de que
el expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
podía estar preparando un golpe para
perpetuarse del poder hoy hemos conocido
que la policía federal ha encontrado un
documento comprometedor en el teléfono
móvil del teniente coronel maurosid uno
de sus más estrechos colaboradores es la
foto de un documento enviado a un
contacto de su teléfono en que vemos un
paso a paso de cómo implementar un
régimen militar en Brasil e incluso se
habla de la posibilidad del estado de
sitio sabemos que finalmente bolsonaron
no contó con el apoyo de las altas
escalones de las fuerzas armadas de
Brasil y tuvo que desistir de su plan a
pesar de un intento el 8 de enero de
este año de invasión de la plaza de los
tres poderes y de los principales
edificios institucionales recordamos que
maurosid es su era su colaborador más
estrecho está en la cárcel a la espera
de y es el mismo que intentó rescatar el
aduana de Brasil las joyas que Yair
bolsonaro intentaba traerse de Arabia
sin declarar también hay que recordar
que no es el primer plan que la policía
encuentra justo después de los actos
golpistas de enero se encontró en el
despacho de Anderson Torres el
exministro de justicia de bolsonaro
también una minuta un documento que
hablaría de golpe en aquel momento se
quiso quitar hierro al asunto El caso es
que Anderson Torres también fue
arrestado por omisión y participación en
un intento de golpe viendo el
informativo gracias por su sintonía
[Música]